how does the DreamWorks Fisher boys sit
on a crescent moon the rest of the moon
is still there right I don't know what
happened to the moon and is the earth
dead yet and I don't care if you a bait
that gives fish orgasms fishing on the
moon usually yields negative results
damn Spielberg out Disney's Disney by 5
seconds for a massive 32 second logo
this is Berk cliche narration is cliche
cliche the only problems are the pests
how does a village have the money to
support life with constant dragon
attacks these dragons are not only
stealing their revenue but also causing
constant damage and who has kids in an
environment like this who are the real
monsters here wooden door sustains
dragon fire my name is hiccup great name
I know hiccup later explains that his
parents believed a terrible name will
ward off gnomes and trolls but we all
know it's because his parents believed
in the power of cartoon marketing I've
been his apprentice ever since I was
little
well little learn the point to pick up
is that he's weak and an underdog but
how can you work in a shop like this for
years without building some muscle and
at the very least looked bigger than
Shaggy oh and that's fishlegs snotlout
the twins ruffnut and tuffnut wheat am I
supposed to know which one is which it
feels like the filmmakers knew I'd want
to be able to know who's who throughout
this film but only half past the
solution killing a dragon is everything
around here but they give you names in
order to ward off trolls and gnomes
dragons no big whoop go kill one gnomes
we need to protect you from those
bitches with a terrible first name of
voodoo power platelet work okay wasn't
he just talking about how it needed
calibrations wasn't he firing basically
blind is this all due to luck or
screenwriter ex machina because hiccup
is the protagonist this dragon chooses
to bite at him rather than breathing
fire or just stepping on his ass
that's not how fire works yeah but he
still has wings and a powerful set jaws
right just because sharks run out of
laser beams doesn't mean they can't kill
any more oh and there's one more thing
you need to know there's one more thing
you need to know narration cliche dad
somehow in this uber badass culture
we're even the weak link it works with
the blacksmith and has the biggest
badass father of them all this kid still
grew into a wimp I can't stop myself I
see a dragon and I have to just count it
yeah that's another thing maybe I can
see this kid growing up a wimp maybe but
somehow developing a Jay Baruchel accent
instead of the Scottish accent these
Vikings apparently possess even though
Vikings are Norse
but still how'd he get back Ava's mess
to clean up you mean the mess hiccup
made was in any way disproportionate to
all the other dragon damage that
occurred in the last 30 minutes
excuse me bottom aide I'm afraid you
brought me the wrong offspring
it's like someone at Pixar just got
drunk watch this movie swamped a gender
or two and brave was born if we find the
nest and destroy it the Dragons will
weep they'll find another hole or a war
they'll get really super mad at you and
burn your entire existence to a crisp
I'm just saying you seem way sure this
suppose it outcome then you have any
reason to be also during the entire
dragon attack did absolutely no one died
knows with me titties no goofing off you
see the later or what why is he even
asking permission you didn't hear it but
the subtitles tell us that someone just
said I have to do my acts returns the
filmmakers were wise not to make that
audible hunting for patrols trolls exist
these steal your socks ball trolls do is
steal socks why are we so afraid of them
that we name our children stupid like
hiccup just to avoid them cops not that
boy father disappointed his son is it
more like in cliche gotta admit the look
at this movie which owes a lot to Roger
Deakins is downright amazing and we can
remove at least three sins for that I
managed to lose an entire dragon well
that dialogue is awfully coincidental to
your forest finding dragon adorability
is a trade I cannot believe they evolved
during the time they also evolved fire
claws jaws and all sorts of killers all
doggins have a limited number of shots
how many does a gronckle doesn't matter
the number because it misses on every
shot
gronckle one always two no net amounts
of time Hawking a fire loogie so that he
can be saved at the last second a dragon
will always always go for the kill
except during this training session
I read words when you could just kill
the stuff the words tell you stuff about
discount Steve Holt for some reason
hiccup waits until night time to come
back to this dragon manual probably
because he knows that when people learn
stuff about things you need to set a
certain mood movie takes its books solve
everything cue from Buffy and Harry
Potter entire Viking existence seems to
revolve around dragons as opposed to you
know Vikings
I'm really beginning to question your
teaching method so am I look for this
blind spot every dragon has one what
really but why it seems like a huge
evolutionary flaw actually I mean should
you even be training with Dragons
capable of wiping out your entire
training grounds in ten seconds our
parents war is about to become ours
figure out which side you're on okay
Astrid seems like kind of a dick
he's clearly on the human side just
because he's terrible at dragon fighting
doesn't mean he wants to see all humans
kill Jesus luckily Dragons understand
human gestures that mean I come in peace
you know despite the fact that I don't
think dragons would ever evolved to be
this cute you got to admit toothless is
a pretty likable character and well he
has to be in order for the store I'm not
made of stone Dan a dragon that
understands that kicking a knife in the
water means peace is definitely confused
about the I want to pet you gesture for
some reason so I can see why people are
afraid of smaller things like snakes and
spiders but why would a dragon have any
reason to be afraid of eels ever intosh
you mind me I'll just back here pick up
things he can just attach his invention
to toothless's tail without him knowing
or caring and even though nothing
happens this is some presumptive right
here this is a survival a dwindling into
single digits now you guys have been
non-stop training for days now and since
when did anybody ever get as much as
hurt much less die so far now think
about what you've done
why would you throw the eel into the
cage people could easily figure out your
newfound cheap method and now you've got
to find another eel also how in the
world does nobody see this from this
vantage point and what about this
gray-haired random person watching from
outside the cage and what happened all
the smoke and gas that was here just ten
seconds ago pickups on toothless rolling
around in grass a second ago and makes
the huge assumption that holding out a
handful of it will make the dragon style
and again how does no one notice that
also hiccup keeps learning things with
this one species of dragon that somehow
work for all species of dragons hiccup
brings a deadly and feared dragon that
he loves into his town that wants to
kill dragons and they make noise right
when Astrid is walking nearby because
the script said so of course he can
barely walk through the village without
being swarmed by his new fans that's
another thing hiccups popularity is such
that I don't understand how a big fan of
his and secretly followed into his
hideout to see the dragon training
hiccup lux acts his way back onto the
dragon after many seconds of
free-falling
while hiccup rides this dragon I can't
help but think discount Atreyu and Alcor
elder who's had an amazing view of all
the training so far still hasn't seen
hiccup do any of his cheats i can't wait
i am so leaving wait he won the honor of
killing the dragon but they didn't make
him do it right there in the ring is it
so he has time to figure out a solution
finally you think someone is suspicious
as her would have figured this out days
ago the hell is she holding on to her
legs are in the air and her hands are in
no position to keep her from falling off
if anyone can fly around in a movie you
can bet the movie will dedicate five
percent of its run time to flying around
kid flies his dragon super close to his
home pound Viking village that live for
killing dragons Tyrannosaurus Smaug no
discount t-rex illa it's one of those
two what are you looking at man
someone could score a viral hit with a
super cut of all the animated movie
characters who have said this to their
animal sidekick in a lame attempt at
comedy promise me it won't go wrong
requesting uncapable promises I can't
believe I'm saying this but this dragon
competition arena is even more deadly
and unsafe than the one in Goblet of
Fire
this here's hiccup screams from I think
it's five miles away during the entire
time toothless tried to fly out here
earlier for survival he never found this
relatively easy wall to climb they
killed hearted roots of us never on
screen though oh no what you're up
against it's like nothing you've ever
seen hiccup says vague bull like this
instead of there are 50,000 dragons
there and one the size of a king
Mountain you're not my son
this asshole finally says what everyone
has always known he thought and it's
presented as some wammy moment I bet
he's really frightened now what are you
gonna do about it and of course he
thinks of what to do immediately after
she says this so not me wondering if
that is in fact a plan at all and what
it may be finding this then taken at
first we sinned the fact that this
unquestioned leader had to go to Council
now that we know there's a council since
when can stoic just do whatever the hell
he wants earlier when they went out to
find the nest he had to appeal to a
council of some sort now he can just
lead a bunch of men into boats without
any knowledge of what they're getting
into
sure toothless is giving directions now
but they had to get to this point for it
to happen how did they know which
direction to sail in the first place I'm
impressed this totally male-dominated
society has a woman warrior too bad they
couldn't give her a line I do not
believe you can punch holes in mountains
by lobbing small rocks at it I just
don't think that makes any logical or
scientific sense at all even if the
mountain is hollow and has walls this
thin you're still on thin ice with me
moving damn this indominus godzilla
waited so long to breathe fire on
stoichea loud time for
next machina also this actually might be
the worst part of a good movie how do
you get dragons which fear their giant
master so much to attack said master not
only that these kids managed to learn
how to fly dragons at the speed of
improvisation a skill which took months
for hiccup to learn oh jesus the
shackles and fire weren't enough phony
rescue tension now we have to sit
through he definitely won't drown either
scene
why hasn't toothless chewed or laser
breath his shackles off yet this is such
an awesome noise he's all business but
there's still that bond underneath it
once in remove for a pure character
moment I'm sorry for everything dad
thinks this is the right time for this
I'm proud to call you my son oh my god
do they later these characters have been
so undeveloped I had no idea there was
some sort of competitive rivalry between
them until this scene nearly at the end
of the movie luckily it services the
plot me either
this asshole chases them a long time
went on firing his killer breath because
protagonists well they're both going to
survive this and the movie isn't going
to give too it's about explaining it so
soon for sure you see because toothless
basically lost a body part that helped
him move around it only makes sense the
hiccup lost something of his own because
symmetry and stuff hiccup learns he lost
a leg and learns to walk on the new
artificial leg all in the span of 1
minute this is Berk repeating earlier
narration only this time with new
understanding or irony cliche it snows
nine months of the year and hails the
other three
that's hilarious but not only is it nice
and sunny as you're saying this but I
don't think I've seen it snow or hail in
this movie maybe it was snowing earlier
on I don't remember but definitely no
fucking hail in this flick happy ending
but don't dragons live for hundreds of
thousands of years this is actually a
tragedy if you think about two plaits
lonely and on his own for decades after
hiccup dies kind of like that few drama
episode about frying his dog
thank you for nothing
you useless reptile
it's located solidly on the meridian of
misery well if there's a bright Center
to the universe you're on the planet
that is farthest from the winter is
coming
scauldron sprays scalding water in its
victim extremely dangerous yeah it's
only a story it's not real it's only a
story
I can show you the world I am the last
one and Astrid
you
I finished sending this film and I still
have no idea how to train my dragon I
get to skip this whole damn movie if
someone had just created this is
actually how to train your dragon calm
using Squarespace so I went ahead and
created this is actually how to train
your dragon calm using Squarespace this
would have been a ridiculous waste of
time and service of a bad joke if
Squarespace wasn't so damn easy and
intuitive to use and it eight dollars a
month I'll be not now I'm the proud
owner of a professional looking site
that has the power and stability to
reach a wide audience of humans needing
to know how to train their little
hellions into kind and considerate
Giants so start your free trial site
today with no credit card required at
squarespace.com when you do decide to
sign up for Squarespace make sure to use
the offer code sins to get 10% off your
first purchase
Squarespace build it beautiful and
seriously guys we built the website and
there's a lot of stuff on it
we'll check it out